on va dire faut que ces personnes ne
peuvent pas s'intégrer
lomé togo le kg elle m'a la c1 c'est un
personnage en fait qu' un déraciné qui
vient plutôt go et ce qui est de la même
façon que jb découvre sans de formation
c'est pour 2 aussi une façon de se
rapprocher l'école y amener dans ses
valises quelques citations de son père
pour apporter toute sa philosophie
gibles suffira pas le sens du ferry il
attire la sympathie
parce qu'il vient loin il a il fait une
grosse croix sur tout ce qu'il a connu
jusque là pour sa passion ça c'est la
classe internationale
ward aussi à gérer la petite anaïs 18
ans à mal
elle est là les gars sont star avec alma
là ça commence un petit peu avec le chat
et la souris secours beaucoup après el
malah lui court après elle lui tend la
main pierre va reprendre ce qu'elle lui
donne jusqu'à la fin du film je dois
peut-être qu'ils se concentrent plus sur
le foot gay sur les filles mais ça se
passe bien